[Musique]
or là dans les continents pour toute
chose d'assez lance t elle
[Musique]
il était maoïstes à la fin des années 80
et donc il a même été un dissident de en
faveur de davantage de liberté de
démocratie et dilettante isolés par la
suite qu'il était un peu considérée
comme un de l'indépendant un de vos
moins de démocratie
ça n'a pas empêché par la suite d'être
dans la droite la plus conservatrice du
pays à partir du moment la slovénie 1 et
indépendante
[Musique]
il était déjà premier ministre lorsque
la slovénie a présidé l'union européenne
en 2008 au premier semestre
il était tout à fait pour la
construction européenne actuelle puisque
la slovénie a adhéré à l'union
européenne en 2004 à l'espace à la zone
euro au 1er janvier 2007 à l'espace
schengen 21 décembre 2007 et ce qui fait
que lorsque la slovénie a présidé
l'union européenne elle était déjà
complètement intégré dans les
institutions européennes
donc il y en a en 2008 ils pouvaient pas
véritablement s'opposer à la course au
kérosène tous les partis politiques et
la grande très grande majorité des
slovènes étaient en faveur de la
construction européenne telle qu'elle
était à l'époque
[Musique]
dire j politique comme en pologne
hongrie qui tend non seulement à défier
l'union européenne mais aussi est à
remettre en cause un certain nombre
d'acquis de liberté individuelle ou
collective et il ya une chasse à
s'inscrit dans cette logique
[Musique]
c'est son modèle c'est certain et
probablement que le feq sorbonne son
pouvoir depuis dix ans hongrie sur ce
credo l'encouragent beaucoup avec l'idée
est justement de continuer sur cette
voie pour garder le pouvoir
car si tu relis que les postes qu'on a
quand même de redonner ce n'est rien
pauli caractères autorisés postale
pour
injurieux à l'égard journalistes est
dans un cas précis y compris dans ce cas
précis ce soir
absolument
[Musique]
je
est-ce que ça va être un moment où le
premier ministre slovène va pouvoir
avoir une tribune privilégiée pour
partager un certain nombre de ses
opinions avec le soutien d'autres
régimes qui remettent en cause la
construction européenne actuelle c'est
pas impossible
est-ce qu'on va avoir des provocations
extrêmement déplacé et forte
c'est pas impossible non plus salée le
propre de ces personnalités politiques
c'est que elles sont toujours là on ne
les attend pas tout peut se produire
dans les six prochains mois mais il faut
pas non plus donner une importance qu'il
en a une présidence de l'union
européenne c'est pas la présidence de
l'union européenne qui donne une
orientation à la politique de ben y'a
d'autres institutions ont beaucoup plus
de points une présidence européenne
[Musique]